[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory while
there are likely many wizards that come
to mind when you think of harry potter
and evil gelat grindelwald and lord
voldemort to name a few the title of
most evil which may not be quite so
obvious
so in this video we're going to be
discussing why i believe that the most
evil witch in the harry potter universe
is one gomlar gaunt
now i know what you may be thinking
who in merlin's beard is gorm le gaunt
wouldn't bellatrix estranged the obvious
choice for most evil witch could she
possibly be more evil than bellatrix the
literal mistress of evil reincarnate
well of course bellatrix was a truly
evil bit er witch she performed some
incredibly cruel and heinous acts of
magic and non-magic for that matter in
the name of being one of lord
voldemort's death eaters in fact the
rumor is that bellatrix was so devout to
voldemort in the dark arts that she
actually fell in love and was intimate
with the dark lord himself producing a
daughter named delphi
taking the vows of a death eater quite
above and beyond if you ask me
but anyway in addition to her absolute
loyalty to voldemort bellatrix was also
involved in some of the most disturbing
acts of dark magic described throughout
harry potter
for example she took part in the torture
of auras frank and alice longbottom
an act which drove them both mad and
permanently landed them in saint mongo's
hospital for magical maladies and
injuries for the remainder of their
lives she also committed many a murder
including that of beloved house elf
dobby her own cousin sirius black and
her niece nymphadora tonks and she did
all this in the name of pure blood
supremacy and the dark world division of
the wizarding world
so yes of course it's true belichick's
the strange was a monstrously evil witch
but hundreds of years before there was
belichick's estranged there was an irish
witch by the name of gom lagondt whose
acts of unspeakable evil
rival mistler strangers to the point in
which i must admit that in my opinion
she was indeed the more evil of the two
so first things first who was gorm
lagant well as i'm sure you've deduced
by her surname gormla was part of the
house of gaunt a prominent fanatically
pureblooded lineage in europe the gorns
are among those listed in the sacred 28
a directory of pure blood wizarding
families which was created in the first
half of the 1900s they were enormously
proud of their ancestry as they were the
descendants of salazar slytherin one of
the four founders of hogwarts school of
witchcraft and wizardry and believer of
pure blood supremacy and cadmus peverell
the most arrogant of the three brothers
who originally possessed the deathly
hallows and served as inspiration for
the tales of the three brothers
tom riddle who of course became lord
voldemort was also a member of the house
of gaunt as was his mother murabi gaunt
daughter of marvolo
with relatives like these it's not too
hard to imagine that gormla would be one
of the nastiest witches to have ever
lived of course gormla was around long
before voldemort and well after salazar
slytherin and cadmus peverell as she was
born in the latter part of the 16th
century
much of what is known about gormle's
life actually revolves around her famous
niece is old ser one of the founders of
ilvermorny school of witchcraft and
wizardry the north american school of
magic located among massachusetts mount
greylock in fact it is her actions
towards azolt and his old immediate
family that in my opinion have garnered
her the title of most evil witch in the
wizarding world of harry potter let's
take a look shall we as you may recall
the gaunts were so intent on the
preservation of their pure bloodline
that they would often marry their own
cousins so it's definitely not an
understatement to say that the house of
gaunt was fervent in their belief of
blood purity
gormla was no exception
like many of her ancestors she possessed
the ability to speak in parcel tongue a
rare talent which allowed her to
communicate with snakes
this was just one of the gifts passed
down to gormler from salazar slytherin
and she was also in possession of this
powerful wizard's original wand
it is known that gormless sister did not
share in the family's extreme
anti-muggle sentiments and the two were
rather estranged however although they
were not familiar gormland knew that her
sister had produced a daughter izolt
gormler also became aware that her
sister and brother-in-law were secretly
helping unsuspecting muggles with minor
maladies and farm work and so it is said
that gormler was so horrified by her
sister's friendly interactions with
local muggles that she became concerned
for her niece's future how could she
allow a pureblood ancestor of salazar
slytherin to grow up a blood traitor
intermingling and aiding non-magical
folk and so gormla in an effort to
redirect izolt's life killed her own
sister and her sister's husband by
burning down their home with the two of
them inside
but not before rescuing a zolt from the
fire it would seem that in gormla's
twisted mind the murder of her closest
blood relative was justified and that
she was saving assault from a life that
may have led the girl to accept non-pure
bloods or worse muggles as you can
imagine childhood with an aunt like
gormla was not a happy one for young
adults for results entire youth gormla
kept her isolated in a valley known as
kumquali forcing the young girl to watch
as she cursed any living thing that came
their way
causing misery and pain to both her
victims as well as to poor results
also prevented her niece from attending
hogwarts fearing that she would only be
exposed to mud bloods and half bloods in
an all too tolerant environment
instead gormla took it upon herself to
teach us old magic although she never
permitted the girl to have her own wand
and kept her in line through the use of
dark magic
gormla kept the girl under this kind of
restraint for years it was over a decade
before azolt was finally able to make
her escape after she had fled gormless
searched for result for many years in
vain determined to find her niece so
that she could go back to enforcing her
fervent anti-muggle ideologies on the
young woman
fortunately for result she was able to
travel undetected to north america where
she eventually fell in love with a
muggle and founded ilvermorny a school
of witchcraft and wizardry which today
has a reputation as one of the most
progressive and tolerant of its kind
when news of this american wizarding
school reached gormla in ireland she
deduced that her estranged niece must be
involved as ilvermorny was the namesake
of results first home the one which
gormler had destroyed when she had
murdered the girl's parents as you can
imagine gormler was furious
gormler set out to america at once to
seek her revenge for the very things she
had hoped to prevent seemed to have come
true
izzolt was not only tolerant of muggles
she was in love with one a james steward
the two had even gotten married and had
two twin girls martha and ryonok
upon her arrival at ilvermorny gormler
attempted to use her parcel tongue and
dark magic abilities to murder result in
her husband james
thankfully her plans were foiled by two
teenage wizards chadwick and webster
whom izzolt and james had adopted the
power of love and a pukwudgie named
william whom result had befriended many
years previous ultimately it was the
pakwaji a magical being native to
america and distantly related to the
goblins of europe who killed gormla with
one of his poisonous arrows
if you ask me it was a fitting end for
which most evil
a woman who had spent her entire life in
the pursuit of pure blood supremacy at
any cost including murdering members of
her own family and holding a niece
hostage for years with the use of dark
magic was killed with a fatal arrow to
the heart a poisonous arrow for a
poisonous heart seems like poetic
justice does it not
and that brings us to the end of this
video what do you think does all this
rightfully give gorm la gaunt the title
of most evil witch in the harry potter
universe or is there another wedge that
i've overlooked let me know your
thoughts in the comments below
and as always if you enjoyed this video
don't forget to like it and to subscribe
to the channel until next time those
cunning folk use any means to achieve
their ends
[Music]